nomen verb verbindungen b2 c1 eine
sitzung abhalten
eine sitzung abhalten
sie halten eine sitzung ab sie halten
eine sitzung ab
im gute stimmung seien in guter stimmung
sein
ich bin in guter stimmung
ich bin in guter stimmung unter strafe
stehen unter strafe stehen
wir stehen unter strafe der polizei wir
stehen unter strafe der polizei auf
kritik stoßen auf kritik stoßen
ich stoße auf viel kritik ich stoße auf
viel kritik
in angst versetzen in angst versetzen
das virus versetzt mich in angst
die aufmerksamkeit ziehen auf und
akkusativ die aufmerksamkeit ziehen auf
und akkusativ er zieht die ganze
aufmerksamkeit auf sich
er zieht die ganze aufmerksamkeit auf
sich
hilfe leisten hilfe leisten kann mir
jemand hilfe leisten kann mir jemand
hilfe leisten
frieden schließen frieden herrscht
wir haben frieden geschlossen jetzt
herrscht frieden
wir haben frieden geschlossen
jetzt herrscht frieden
unter zeitdruck stehen unter zeitdruck
stehen
heute stehe ich unter großem zeitdruck
vor gericht stehen
ich stehe vor gericht ich stehe vor
gericht in empfang nehmen
in empfang nehmen
die chefin nimmt sie gleich in empfang
in streik treten in streik treten
wir treten jetzt in streik wir treten
jetzt in streik
gesellschaft leisten gesellschaft
leisten
darf ich euch gesellschaft leisten darf
ich euch gesellschaft leisten darf ich
euch gesellschaft leisten
in betrieb sein in betrieb sein
diese maschine funktioniert sie ist in
betrieb diese maschine funktioniert
sie ist in betrieb außer atem sein außer
atem sein
ich bin völlig außer atem ich bin völlig
außer atem vorbereitungen treffen
vorbereitungen treffen
der vorbereitungen getroffen und einen
regenschirm mitgenommen
ich habe vorbereitungen getroffen und
einen regenschirm mitgenommen
enttäuschung bereiten enttäuschung
bereiten
ich habe den marathon verloren das
bereitet mir enttäuschung
ich habe den marathon verloren
das bereitet mir enttäuschung
auf die nerven gehen auf die nerven
gehen
kinder ihr geht mir auf die nerven
ein referat halten über und akkusativ
heute halte ich ein referat über die
schwierigkeiten meines berufes
abonniere unseren kanal hallo deutsch
schule
möchtest du doch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video